SPEECH.
>> Laura: THEY'RE YELLING AT ME.
I HAVE TO GO.
>> Sean: HAVE FUN.
>> Laura: SEE YA.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT FROM
WASHINGTON.
YOU HEARD A FEDERAL JUDGE JUST
STRUCK DOUBT JOE BIDEN'S STUDENT
FORGIVENESS LOAN PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN RULED AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL EXERCISE OF
POWER.
BIDEN DOESN'T CARE.
THE ELECTION IS OVER.
THE FREE MONEY GOOSE THE YOUTH
VOTE ENOUGH TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
PERHAPS.
IT'S A COMPLETE DISGRACE.
SPEAKING OF ABOMINATIONS, THE
ENDLESS VOTE COUNT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT.
NOW 45 HOURS OR SO AFTER THE
LAST POLLS IN AMERICA CLOSED AND
THERE ARE STILL 36 RACES, 33 IN
THE HOUSE AND THREE IN THE
SENATE THAT STILL HAVEN'T BEEN
CALLED.
EXCEPT IN THE CASE OF AUTOMATIC
RECOUNTS, WHICH ARE TRIGGERED BY
RAZOR THIN MARGINS.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
THESE OBSCENE DELAYS ARE HAVING
REAL WORLD IMPLICATIONS.
NOW, WE STILL DON'T KNOW FOR
CERTAIN WHICH PARTY CONTROLS
EITHER CHAMBER.
THE HOUSE WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY
GO TO THE GOP, BUT THE SENATE
HANGS IN THE BALANCE.
SO WHICHEVER PARTY WINS TWO OF
THE THREE REMAINING STATES,
GEORGIA, NEVADA OR ARIZONA WILL
CONTROL THE SENATE.
WE HAVE NO OUTCOME IN ANY OF
THOSE.
IN GEORGIA, THEY'RE EXCUSED I
GUESS BECAUSE NEITHER HERSCHEL
WALKER OR RAPHAEL WARNOCK
RECEIVED OVER 50% OF THE VOTE
TRIGGERING A RUN-OFF.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN ARIZONA AND
NEVADA IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
>> THERE ARE 665,000 MORE VOTES
THAT NEED TO BE COUNTED.
120,000 VOTES STILL NEED TO BE
COUNTED IN NEVADA.
>> 300 BOXES THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY AND THAT'S WHAT'S BEING
COUNTED RIGHT NOW.
>> WE GOT THAT UPDATE FROM THE
CLARK COUNTY REGISTRAR THAT THEY
HAVE MORE THAN 50,000 BALLOTS
THAT NEED TO BE COUNTED.
>> Laura: SOMEHOW WE WERE ABLE
TO BECOME THE MOST POWERFUL
NATION ON THE FACE OF THE PLANET
BY VOTING AND CALLING IMPORTANT
RACES IN ONE DAY.
IN RECENT HISTORY, WE ELECTED
TWO DEMOCRATS EACH TO TWO TERMS,
OBAMA AND CLINTON TWICE UNDER A
SYSTEM WHERE WE KNEW THE WINNER
ON ELECTION NIGHT.
FAIR ENOUGH THEN, CORRECT?
NOW WE'RE SEEING A NEW NORMAL OF
ELECTIONS UNFOLD EVERY FEW
YEARS.
IN A NUMBER OF BATTLEGROUND
STATES OUTCOMES ARE NOT
DETERMINED FOR DAYS AND MAYBE
WEEKS AFTER ELECTION DAY.
SO FOR THE ENTIRE ELECTION
SEASON, REMEMBER THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS ISSUING ALL OF THESE STERN
WARNINGS ABOUT THE DIRE THREATS
TO OUR ELECTIONS?
PRESUMABLY, OF COURSE.
JUST FROM NEFARIOUS MEGAMAGA
FORCES.
>> THINK OF ALL WE HEARD BEFORE
THIS ELECTION ABOUT ALL OF THE
PEOPLE BEING INTIMIDATED, ALL OF
THE PEOPLE BEING THREATENED AT
THE POLLS AND THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK THE POLLS.
IT WAS THE FIRST NATIONAL
ELECTION SINCE JANUARY 6 AND
THERE WERE A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT WHETHER DEMOCRACY WOULD
MEET THE TEST.
IT DID.
>> Laura: IT'S AMAZING HOW THE
DEMOCRATS OUTPERFORMING STOPPED
ALL OF THAT VOTER SUPPRESSION.
THE FACT IS THEY NEVER BELIEVED
THEIR ELECTION HYPERBOLE.
IT WAS ANOTHER ELECTION PLOY TO
HELP RALLY THEIR BASE.
>> WE SAW EXTRAORDINARY RESULTS
IN THE MID-TERMS THAT NOBODY
THOUGHT POSSIBLE.
WE GOT A RESULT AND WE ACCEPTED
IT.
EVERYBODY ACCEPTED IT.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, THE ARE
RESULTS ARE NOT ALL IN, JOE.
LIKE HE'S NOT ALL THERE.
INSTEAD WE HAVE RANDOM
ANNOUNCEMENTS THROUGHOUT THE DAY
WHICH FEW AMERICANS CAN EVEN
FOLLOW OR UNDERSTAND LIKE WHAT
WE'RE SEEING OUT OF MARICOPA
COUNTY WHERE THEY STILL HAVE A
STAGGERING 400,000 VOTES TO
COUNT.
>> WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE THE
VOTES WILL BE COUNTED IN TOTAL,
THE 400,000 PLUS VOTES?
>> WE HAVE -- WE WILL BE GOING
INTO NEXT WEEK.
THERE'S SOME ONCIES, TWOSSIES
PURSUANT TO ARIZONA LAW.
THE LIONS SHARE WILL WRAP UP
NEXT WEEK.
>> ARE WE TALKING MONDAY?
>> MAY BE.
DON'T HOLD ME TO IT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AT
THIS POINT.
>> Laura: WHY SHOULD WE HOLD
ANYBODY TO ANYTHING?
WHY RUSH?
NOTHING IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS.
YOU KNOW, THE DEFENDERS OF
DEMOCRACY, YOU REALLY HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THEM.
THEY'RE WORKING LONG HOURS.
>> TO THOSE PEOPLE THAT DEMAND
THAT WE MOVE FASTER WITH THE
COUNT, THEY ARE ALREADY WORKING
14 TO 18 HOURS A DAY.
WE CAN'T GO ANY FURTHER THAN
THAT.
>> Laura: WE CAN'T GO ANY
FASTER.
IF DEMOCRACY IS REALLY ON THE
LINE LIKE BIDEN SAID, WHY DIDN'T
THEY HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE TO HANDLE THIS?
THEY WERE GETTING SNIPPY TODAY I
NOTICED AT THEIR PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> WHY IS IT TAKING THE AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT IT'S TAKING?
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THE GOAL
POSTS HAVE CHANGED.
ALL RIGHT?
THE REASON THAT THE GOAL POSTS
HAVE CHANGED IS BECAUSE
WONDERFUL NEWS.
WE HAD 290,000 MAIL-IN BALLOTS
DROPPED OFF AT OUR VOTE CENTERS
ON ELECTION DAY.
THAT BROKE THE PREVIOUS RECORD
BY 70%.
>> Laura: WHY DIDN'T YOU HAVE
THE STAFF IN PLACE?
YOU THINK REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
DUCEY WOULD HAVE FIXED THIS
MESS?
SAME DAY, DROP OFF VOTING SOUNDS
NIFTY BUT NOT IF YOU CAN'T COUNT
THE VOTES.
AGAIN, NOT ROCKET SCIENCE.
I REALIZE THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW
THESE RULES THAT ARIZONA HAS IN
PLACE.
BUT THIS SCREWED UP SYSTEM IS SO
CORROSIVE THAT IT JUST -- IT
CHIPS AWAY AT THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE.
THEY WANT ACCURATE OUTCOMES.
THEY DON'T THINK THEY'RE GETTING
THEM.
BUT OBVIOUS EVERYONE IN THE
PRESS WILL BRAND ANY OBJECTION
RAISED BY ANY REPUBLICAN ABOUT
ALMOST ANY ASPECT OF VOTING AS
WACKY, ELECTION DENIER
CONSPIRACY THEORY STUFF.
I SAY TOO BAD.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE REASONS FOR
AMERICANS OF BOTH PARTIES TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW STATES THAT
ALLOW BALLOT HARVESTING,
AUTOMATIC MAIL-IN BALLOTS, PRO
DIRECTED EARLY VOTING, DROP
BOXES, FLIMSY VOTER VERIFICATION
OR WEAK ELECTION MONITORS, HOW
THEY ALL OPERATE.
IT'S LEGITIMATE TO QUESTION IT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THE SCRIPT
WAS FLIPPED IN ARIZONA AND THE
SECRETARY STATE WAS A
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN IN
CHARGE OF THE ELECTIONS AND JUST
HAPPENED TO BE RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE LIKE KATIE HOBBS IS?
YEAH, LIKE GOVERNOR KATIE HOBBS
IS OBVIOUSLY.
IN NEVADA WHERE REPUBLICAN ADAM
LAXALT HOPE TOS PICK-OFF
DEMOCRAT INCUMBENT CORTEZ MASTO.
THINGS ARE NOT MUCH BETTER.
>> WE STILL HAVE OVER 50,000
BALLOTS THAT NEED TO BE COUNTED.
THOSE ARE IN VARIOUS STAGES IN
THE PROCESS OF VALIDATION BEFORE
THEY GO TO THE COUNTING BOARD
AND FINALLY ULTIMATELY THEY GET
TO TABULATION WHERE WE'RE ABLE
TO READ THEM IN TO THE SYSTEM.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH
THE WEEKEND.
>> Laura: OH, WORKING THROUGH
THAT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
THOUSANDS OF MAIL-IN BALLOTS
STILL UNCOUNTED.
>> THE MAJORITY OF THE MAIL
SHOULD BE COUNTED IN CLARK
COUNTY BY SATURDAY.
BARRING ANY ISSUES WITH
EQUIPMENT.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE CURE
BALLOTS WITH DEADLINE WILL BE
MONDAY.
>> Laura: NOW, LAS VEGAS AND
CLARK COUNTY, RIGHT?
THAT'S WHERE IT IS?
I DON'T KNOW WHY ANYBODY WOULD
BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF ANYTHING UNUSUAL
HAPPENING WITH VOTES COLLECTED
FROM VEGAS.
RIGHT?
NONE OF THIS SHOULD BE
HAPPENING.
JUST AS WE'VE CONDITIONED
GENERATIONS OF EMPLOYEES TO WORK
FROM HOME, WE'VE CONDITIONED OUR
CITIZENS TO WANT TO VOTE WITHOUT
ANY EFFORT.
DEMOCRATS SAW OPENINGS TO MAKE
MAIL-IN BALLOTS PERMANENT DURING
COVID.
THE PRESS LOVES THIS PROLONGED
POST ELECTION UNCERTAINTY.
IT'S GOOD FOR RATINGS AND
USUALLY GOOD FOR DEMOCRATS.
THEY'RE ULTIMATE MASTERS.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE LEFT WITH A
CHOICE.
WE CAN EITHER HAVE A VOTING
SYSTEM WITH MORE TRANSPARENCY
AND CLARITY OR ONE THAT ERODES
TRUST IN THE PROCESS.
NOW, IN THE LATTER SCENARIO LIKE
FLORIDA, HALF OF THE COUNTRY
WILL VOTE AND HAVE A WINNER ON
ELECTION DAY.
THE OTHER HALF OF THE COUNTRY
WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THINGS
LIKE WHAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT.
BEWARE WHAT IS ALREADY UNFOLDING
IN THE GEORGIA RUN-OFF AS WELL.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY PLAN TO SPEND $7 MILLION ON
GET OUT THE VOTE EFFORTS THERE.
TRANSLATION, BALLOT HARVESTING.
THAT WILL BE FUNDED.
WHY DOES GEORGIA STILL ALLOW
BALLOT HARVESTING?
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
31 STATES ALLOW THE RIDICULOUS
PROCESS AS WELL.
BUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THIS,
YOU HAVE TO HAND IT TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY'LL DO ALMOST ANYTHING, GO
TO ALMOST ANY LENGTHS TO
MAXIMIZE THEIR CHANCES OF
WINNING.
THE MAN BEHIND THE BOGUS
CONCERNS OVER VOTER SUPPRESSION
HAS BEEN AT THIS FOR YEARS.
THAT MOVEMENT HELPED PROPEL THE
ADOPTION OF SOME OF THE OBSCENE
RULES THAT WE SEE TODAY.
>> IF THE REPUBLICANS WANT LESS
LITIGATION ENGAGE IN LESS VOTER
SUPPRESSION, I'LL MAKE THEM A
DEAL.
IF THEY STOP SUPPRESSING THE
VOTE, I WILL STOP SUING THEM.
>> I THINK WE'RE ONE, MAYBE TWO
ELECTION CYCLES AWAY FROM A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS BECAUSE
YOU NOW HAVE ONE OF THE TWO
MAJOR PARTIES IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT IS NO LONGER COMMITTED TO
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS.
>> Laura: SO WORRIED ABOUT
PRESERVING PUBLIC TRUST IN OUR
ELECTIONS.
MARC ELIAS' FORM WORKED TO
SUPPRESS THE HAND COUNTING OF
BALLOTS BY ONE RURAL ARIZONA
COUNTY.
THAT COUNTY PROPOSED DOING SO
DUE TO CONCERNS OVER THE
OPERATION OF THE VOTING
MACHINES.
ELIAS WON.
A JUDGE BLOCKED THE HAND COUNT
THERE AND CANDIDATE SECRETARY OF
STATE KATIE HOBBS, HER NAME WAS
ON THE BRIEF.
REPUBLICANS THOUGH, COME ON,
THEY NEED THEIR OWN VERSION OF
MARC ELIAS.
COMPLAIN ABOUT HIM BUT HE'S
SUCCESSFUL.
MAYBE SOMEBODY NOT AS SLIMY BUT
WE NEED SOMETHING LIKE HIM.
FOR YEARS NOW, WE'VE BEEN TOLD
WE HAVE TO TRUST ANY ELECTION
PROCESS THAT IS REASON BY
DEMOCRATS.
NO MATTER HOW LONG IT TAKES, NO
MATTER HOW MANY LAWSUITS ARE
FILED, NO MATTER HOW UNFAIR IT
SEEMS.
THE DEMOCRATS RULE IS SIMPLE.
YOU CAN CRITICIZE AN UMPIRE,
CRITICIZE THE SUPREME COURT OR
ANY REPUBLICAN IN PUBLIC OFFICE
BUT YOU MUST NEVER EVER
CRITICIZE THE VOTE COUNT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING WITH
FIRE HERE.
BECAUSE NO AMOUNT OF PROPAGANDA
WILL CONVINCE POPULOUS VOTERS
THAT THE PROCESS IN STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA, ARIZONA AND NEVADA
GIVES THEIR CANDIDATES A FAIR
CHANCE AT SUCCESS.
IF THE DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT TO
BUILD TRUST IN OUR INSTITUTIONS,
THEY WOULD AGREE TO MORE
TRANSPARENT VOTING SYSTEMS THAT
GIVE US RESULTS ON ELECTION
NIGHT.
JUST LIKE WE USED TO HAVE.
BUT THEY'D RATHER UNDERMINE THE
SYSTEM SO THEY CAN IMPROVE THEIR
CHANCES OF WINNING.
IT'S COMPLETELY SHAMEFUL.
BUT THEY WON'T CHANGE UNTIL IT
BACKFIRES